welcome everybody to long crime daily
i'm jesse weber in for brian buckmeyer
along with terry austin we're now nearly
two weeks into jury selection in the
trial for the death of a mod arbory in
all 64 jurors are planned to be selected
and then that number will be whittled
down to 16 before the trial can begin
for the three georgia men accused of
arbory's murder gregory and travis
mcmichael and william roddy bryan face
charges of malice murder felony murder
and aggravated assault in the shooting
of the 25 year old in february 2020
prosecutors say that father and son duo
gregory and travis mcmichael tailed
arbory in a pickup truck while he was
out for a jog near his brunswick georgia
home travis mcmichael opened fire and
killed arbory claiming self-defense
brian followed along in his own vehicle
recording the incident on his phone jury
selection began for all three men last
monday in glenn county georgia and
that's where law and crime daily host
brian buckmeyer joins us now live and
brian it's good to see you you spoke
with aubry's mother today correct about
her thoughts on jury selection so far
what can you tell us
yes jesse so just looking a little
further back we started with 19 jurors
this morning started a little late
because one was running late actually
but quickly went to questions
eliminating many of those 19 jurors in
fact four jurors today said they knew
ahmad and when jason sheffield the
defense attorney for one of the
mcmichael's trappers michael
specifically asked two questions that
seemed to have possibly eliminated a
number of jurors as well with eight
jurors saying they already had a
negative impression of travis mcmichael
and the other defendants and also they
had a negative impression on the delay
in the prosecution of this case now as
you said wanda cooper jones also came up
and spoke to me about the jury selection
process both about her son and how they
wanted the jury to know who he was but
also about the jury selection process as
a whole juana cooper jones said while
she may be soft-spoken at times when i
spoke with her her words were powerful
when talking about ahmad and seeking the
right jury for the trial
picking the
correct jurors to to make the correct
decision which is guilty
it's gonna be
very important that we get the right
individuals i feel confident that we'll
get the right individuals because the
same citizens of this county
were able to get out the on the pub
defender of jackie johnson
the day
who waited forever to make an arrest
so i'm confident that they will
have their hearts in a good place and
come in and
and listen to the facts of the case
and make the right decision
brian when you were speaking to wanda
cooper jones how is she feeling you know
during the interview how's she reacting
to the ongoing trial the jury selection
process
the way i would describe miss cooper
jones is is subtle strength when you
speak with her you often have to lean in
to hear what she's speaking about but
she has very strong words about her love
for ahmad armory and also the process
that we're going through she's very
hopeful that this conviction is going to
come about but she's also very proud of
her community and believes that those
here will come to the correct decision
in finding the mcmichaels and brian
guilty of murdering ahmad arbury and
imagine what it's like for her now we
talk about the jury selection process i
got to ask you the million dollar
question it's been lengthy so far are
they getting closer to nailing down the
final jurors did we see any big
revelations in court today
so nothing huge other than many people
know a mod arbory or someone connected
to the case in one way shape or form but
as i said earlier those questions of the
negative implications that people feel
about this case and so it's really
causing a lot of people to be
disqualified yesterday we had six jurors
join that prospective panel of qualified
uh jurors who will be questioned later
down the road today i would be surprised
based on some of the answers that these
prospective jurors gave that we may have
more than even six jurors who add to
that list to get to that magic number of
64. today we started with 42 prospective
jurors that were qualified to be able to
hear uh this case of course ever has a
peremptory challenges to whittle down to
12 jurors and four alternates but i
don't think it's going to happen this
week i would expect it to occur early
next week and you and i had talked
earlier in the day about kind of what
that's going to look like with
preemptory strikes going back and forth
and debating over that so i don't know
we're going to have an end in sight but
uh it's going to be difficult to see
when this actually moves into opening
statements brian thank you so much
reporting back to us appreciate it as
always
it was the video that shocked the nation
an unarmed black jogger 25 year old
ahmad aubrey gunned down in broad
daylight we are going to make sure that
we find justice in this case the three
men charged will now stand trial i told
him stop stop stop till he hit me i had
nothing to do
there's nothing else i can do you're a
passer buyer coming through not
necessarily
that's my son that shot him i was in the
back of the truck
starting october 18th watch live capital
gavel coverage on the law and crime
network